[Музика]
привіт усім мене звуть Анна. Сьогодні я
вчитель англійської мови,
ми збираємося завершити нашу
подорож англомовними країнами, тому ми
збираємося поїхати до Великобританії в останній
раз у цій темі
О чі-су анонімно  або воркувати ага Ніна
переміщає Варшам відкрила скарб,
але алюмінієва карта України з часом знаходиться
на Британії
yep of taurima's vomit або material akima
Presley's at mo, тож давайте подивимося
на перше, чим ми поділимося з
вами, також розділена дилема спеціального купона
це копійка в день, давайте рабу ehe, так що
відразу ж у вас є завдання взяти аркуш
паперу в цій катуванні мідбоса і написати
на ньому,
які зображення, на вашу думку, асоціюються з
Великобританією, вирішують, які п'ять найкращих
англійських предметів podomatic epi trash a
velocity  u це, оскільки Britannia є pachitea,
тому запишіть їх у список
праворуч, ви можете побачити, що є ще один список,
який ви повинні скласти, які п'ять
речей, на вашу думку, є найважливішими в
Україні, запишіть їх у список a
ну подумайте, що британці могли б
подумати про Україну першим, коли їм
задають таке запитання, шоу
Майя задумливість Британія крокомір
yekke був на прізвисько Mr.  ДіПальма з
Mahabharata Levinas Britannia подумайте про
це та запишіть у список, тож тепер у вас
є 20 секунд, щоб зробити це
добре, так що час закінчився, подивіться на
ваш список і давайте порівняємо його з моїм,
тож ось мої асоціації з Великою
Британією  або Judah більшість годин, які
використовують димаджіо, Британія,
які прагне до PID, але ви можете знайти деякі
з асоціацій у своєму списку, тому
вперше ви можете побачити
сам автобус, тому двоповерхові
автобуси є важливою річчю  Велика
Британія, тому всі знають, що
двоповерхові ухилення – це Найя,
хто їсть за один, але жовтень
подивіться ключ, він зробив довгі джинси, так що
це дуже важлива риса
Великобританії, що ще важливо, що
ще ми знаємо про це, звичайно, п’ять
годинний чай Леді Діана ми насправді
говорили про леді Діану на попередньому
уроці, а сьогодні ми продовжимо
розмову про неї, але за кілька хвилин,
добре,
які ще асоціації у мене виникають,
можливо, ви  до Шекспіра, звичайно,
Вільям Шекспір, найвідоміший
драматург Великобританії Королева, ви
можете побачити слово Королева, і це,
звісно, для королеви Англії Єл
завети II, що ще ми можемо побачити тут, що
е ми можемо помітити в цій схемі ри
а та чіпси  найвідоміша їжа у
Великобританії, звичайно,
всі знають, що у Великобританії
є королівська сім'я, яка
править країною, а країною
Великобританії є Вестмінстерське королівство,
звідки Вестмінстерське абатство
також важлива особливість футбольних пабів
Шекспір уже згадував Британський му
ей, який ми маємо  ми вже говорили про це
на одному з наших попередніх уроків
і Хай-стріт, яка є однією з
найвідоміших вулиць Лондона, добре, тому тепер, коли
ви активували свої знання про
Британію, і тепер ми розуміємо, що ми
збираємося працювати з певною інформацією
з  що пов'язано з леді Діаною,
тепер давайте перейдемо до наступної вправи,
парадигми vitae, і Донна припини наївну
прибуток, щоб  на дошці ви можете побачити два
стовпці зі словами, які ми побачимо
пізніше в тегах, які ми будемо
читати, тому наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб зіставити
слова зліва з їх
синонімами праворуч.
Джемайма патока не отримає повільного значення
для кожного рівня завдання промоутер трясе
їх зараз викрадати або все ж не наполягати, що
любов анонімна, тому ці слова мають подібне
значення, давайте подивимося на перший
стовпець у лівій колонці, перш ніж
почати виховувати Слава в інтересах
природні причини скасування депресивного
розладу та фатальний, тому ми  Можна припустити, що
життя леді Діани було не дуже щасливим,
насправді воно було не дуже щасливим в
кінці, але до цього у неї було
досить щасливе життя, тому праворуч ми
бачимо слова, які нам потрібно буде зіставити
зі словами  у лівій колонці давайте
подивимося на них всередині місій чисте
дитинство нещастя хвороба увага
смертельний кінець зірковість, тож ось
слова, які нам потрібно знайти, давайте почнемо
з першого, перше слово –
upbringi  Тож коли ви почуєте слово
виховання, ви можете згадати
фразу виховувати, коли ми говоримо про
мозок або виховання зазвичай
пригадує дітей, тож ось як працюють наші
асоціації, і ось як ви
можете здогадатися про значення слова
так виховання  Мая Ваня, і яке
слово ми можемо зіставити зі словом
виховання наш мозок насправді воно
відноситься до дитинства, тому
дитинство - це слово, яке нам потрібно
поєднати виховання в Грузії з гавайським
зануренням - це хвилина, це
анімація дитинства Славенів, напруженого  одна
тому, що зазвичай людей виділяють,
коли вони діти
номер два. Слава, тому, коли ми говоримо про
відомих людей, цих людей знають
усі, синонімом праворуч може
бути слово «зірковість», останнє, це
Джей, тож слава чи слава, давайте перейдемо до
наступне слово номер три всередині колодязя потім
має назву в центрі праворуч, яке
є словом Insight Insight номер чотири
цікавить, що, на вашу думку, може цікавити
синонім із  правильно, так, звичайно
, це G увага, тому, коли ви привернули
увагу, тоді люди зацікавлені в
вас, так що інтерес до уваги або синоніми,
наступне слово є природним, тож яким би могло
бути слово тут, де воно буде
відповідати природним, впевненим, що це чисте, настільки
природне або  чистий просто чистий Родні
наступне слово викликає, тому причини — це центральна
назва слова місії номер сім
скасування скасування насправді є
формальним словом для слова, що закінчується добре
номер вісім депресія, як
правило, стан нещастя, тому це
було б
числом щастя  дев’ять розладів слово
розлад вживається, коли ми говоримо про
те,
що погано функціонує щось, що не працює, це може
стосуватися механізмів, це може бути про
організми, тому, коли ми говоримо про
психічний стан або фізичний стан, ми будемо
говорити, що синонім до  слово «
розлад» було б словом «хвороба»,
а останнє, про що досить легко здогадатися,
тепер число 10
фатальний матиме синонім
справа  у ньому є слово смертельний, так Н смертельний
або фатальний, тому тепер, коли ви знаєте синоніми
зараз, як ви знаєте слова, ми
побачимо їх у тексті, але перш
ніж перейти до тексту, давайте швидко
поглянемо на файл фактів, що  розповідає нам
важливу інформацію про
життя та роботу леді Діани, тож ось файл фактів
про леді Діану, давайте подивимося, Діана
була принцесою Уельською, вона була
активісткою, іконою стилю та однією з
найвпливовіших людей 20-го
століття, вона була  четверта з п'яти
дітей, і вона хотіла бути
балериною, але вона була занадто високою для цього,
але потім вона стала принцесою, яку
насправді не погано замінити
, тому в герцогині Кембриджській
це насправді перший титул леді
Діани, яким вона була  перша королівська наречена, яка
отримала університетську освіту,
тож ви можете собі уявити, якою дивовижною
людиною вона була, тож тепер давайте прочитаємо
історію її життя, послухаємо й прочитаємо наступний
текст Леді Діана Спенсер, яка була
членом британської королівської родини  народилася в 1961 році,
вона мала нормальне тихе виховання, це
ніколи не могло підготувати її до
слави та гламуру, які вона придбала
, будучи британською принцесою, за
кілька років вона перетворилася з сором'язливого
підлітка на найбільш фотографовану людину
на
планеті, яку вона приховувала  газетні заголовки в
усьому світі, але найбільшим
був її смерть у віці 36 років. Діана
була вихователькою в дитячому саду в Лондоні, коли
зацікавилася принцом
Чарльзом, вона підкорила серця нації
своїми шиїтськими посмішками та природною
красою увесь світ  дивилася її казкове
королівське весілля в 1981 році через рік вона
народила принца Вільяма, який був
першим із двох її синів. Діана спочатку нервувала
на публіці, але незабаром у неї
з'явилася чарівна манера, вона проявила
сильний інтерес до багатьох благодійних організацій і
важливих справ  вона наголосила на
стражданнях бездомних людей, які вона
виступала за скасування
наземних мін і багато країн заборонили їх
Діана і Чарльз розлучилися в 1996 році  вона
боролася з депресією та розладами харчової
поведінки протягом багатьох років після того, як вона
нарешті знайшла щастя з єгипетським
кінопродюсером Доді аль-Фаєм. За їхнім
романом пильно стежили
папараці, що призвело до смертельної автомобільної
аварії, у якій вона загинула в Парижі в 1997 році
на її похороні в Британії.  Прем'єр-міністр
Тоні Блер називав її народною
принцесою для багатьох, вона була просто
королевою сердець, тому тепер, коли ви
почули і прочитали текст про леді Діану,
ви знаєте, що вона була дуже чарівною,
вона була дуже веселою людиною і
була дуже жорсткою  -працюючи
зараз, давайте подивимося на вправу
і давайте перевіримо, наскільки добре ви запам’ятали
деякі речі, пов’язані
зі змістом тексту, тому
виберіть правильні слова, виділені курсивом відповідно
до змісту тексту, давайте подивимося
на перше речення  номер один Леді Діана
Спенсер народилася в 1961 році, вона мала
ненормальне, нормальне тихе виховання, тож
давайте подумаємо, чи вона мала нормальне чи
ненормальне виховання, подивіться на
в контексті сина,
перш за все, ви побачите артикль L,
який насправді не можна використовувати перед
словом, яке починається з нижньої частини голосної, або
артилем a, що купа емоцій про
окремі словенські аяти капуцинів, а тепер
не охоплює милю буддійське ожиріння
a хто був  не як контекст Regina Morris
mm Oh II permeate I'm Emma's text, щоб
показати приведення доктора.  дитинство др.  Vega
Vanya lady Gianna Bordeaux sets per
Kingdom it was normal vagina on so
we must use the words normal here number
two it could never готує її
до слави та гламуру або гламурності
бути британською принцесою, ти пам'ятаєш,
яке саме слово було  що було використано
в тексті було це гламур чи це було
гламурно
тут, вам потрібно буде подивитися на
структуру речення Девон був противний
лікар О Регіна та Роуз Амін був застрелений
Слава слава
це в моїй шиї це муна жорсткість
довгі вуса мій Абу  tayi Menachem so
glamorous — це прикметник, а слово
glamour — це іменник, який нам
потрібен тут номер три. Діана була
вихователькою в дитячому садку в Лондоні, коли вона
зловила або зацікавила принца
Чарльза, тому нам потрібно використати
просту форму минулого  дієслово тут, оскільки ми
говоримо про минулі події минулі події,
які вже закінчилися, тому ми
не можемо використовувати дієслово catch tockman
емоційний Christopher J Slavic catch
з Samuel T для мене to mu  shi Maho mo
pro з щойно пухким презервативом динамо-стручка
без прихованого об'єкта слов'янська карта
формально слов'янка я все ще даю
просту мінойську, яку я бачу, тому вона була
вихователькою в дитячому садку в Лондоні, коли
зацікавилася принцом Чарльзом
номер чотири, вона взяла  сильний
інтерес або інтерес до багатьох
благодійних організацій та важливих справ, тому
леді Діана приділяла значну увагу вона
приділяла значну
увагу багатьом благодійним організаціям чи синонім до
уваги бути інтерес або цікавий
цікавий є прикметником
розмови люблю цікаве окреме божевілля
octoroon Донна більше горілка отрута
зазвичай muguara mo  про інтерес
це кальвініст vaho перемістити мій авторитет у
моїй шиї і це було б слово
інтерес наступне речення номер п'ять
вона також агітувала за скасування або
скасування наземних мін і багато країн
заборонили їх, тож ми використовуємо скасування або
скасування в цьому  речення давайте пригадаємо
те, що ми вже бачили на
попередніх слайдах шоу Vitis on Diamond
showmanship o  ведуча холостяка Вікі для
мене це схил чавала ша-на-на
більшість папа-реднеків розум з Колими дуже
низький про синонім отримав шість відпусток, тому ми
мали слово скасування, яке було б
синонімом до слова, а потім так, коли
щось буде закінчено  тут більше не використовується,
нам потрібно використовувати форму іменника
дієслова, який фактично є скасуванням, тому ми
не можемо використовувати дієслово abolish у цьому випадку
номер шість, за їхнім романтичним романом
пильно слідкували папараці, що
призвело до смертельної або смертельної автомобільної аварії,
яка загинула  її в Парижі в 1997 році, тож
давайте спочатку подивимося на
першу частину речення, що це
частина речення перед комою, тож їхній
романтичний або романтичний зв’язок,
так що романс відомий, романтичний — це
прикметник після прикметника, який ми зазвичай
зустрічаємо, щоб використовувати деякі  іменник, але ми не можемо сказати
це прямо там, там є дієслово was, тому
нам потрібно використати іменник або xeomin, яке
буде словом романтика, і давайте
подивимося на другу частину
речення, а тепер зауважте, що я відповів al  більшість
не робот просто заохочує одиниці, прикріплені
до ковпака є likami, тому що призвело до
смертельної або смертельної автомобільної аварії, в якій вона
загинула в Парижі в 1997 році, тож тут
ми в автокатастрофі, то нам потрібно
описати, використовуючи прикметник fatality is
a  іменник, тому нам знадобиться слово фатальний або
оскільки його синонім було смертельним у цьому
реченні, що призвело до смертельної
автокатастрофи, в якій вона загинула в Парижі в 1997 році,
тому тепер, коли ви згадаєте слова
з тексту, давайте ще раз поглянемо на текст
тут ви можете побачити
підкреслені речення, це
насправді речення, які вони визначають, і
невизначальні відносні речення Oh Donna
mote xtk проти бюджету та іронії,
більшість бюджету, який вони показали, вони
могли б просто заохочувати натяк на речення так,
адресовані тільки скажи визначення  про
невизначальні відносні речення пам'ятайте,
що визначальне відносне речення дає нам
важливу інформацію, яку неможливо
вилучити з речення, коли ми
говоримо про невизначальні відносні
речення, які вони надають  нам додаткова не дуже
потрібна інформація зазвичай це
речення відокремлюється комами
Oh Geneva de la moq mimetic a закритий
переворот просто заохочуйте в іншому
всесвіті live informati шум
був Roisin yah prayati Yahoo funk scene yagna Budaj є злим
будь- так давайте
поглянемо на  речення на дошці Леді
Діана Спенсер, яка була членом
британської королівської сім'ї, народилася в 1961 році, чи
може наше речення функціонувати без
частини, яка стоїть між комами так,
звичайно, ми можемо так сказати сьогодні. Яна
Спенсер народилася в 1961 році інформація
після того, хто є зайвим, ми можемо забрати це
або ми можемо створити нове речення з ним,
вона була членом британської королівської сім'ї,
і це буде додаткове нове речення,
давайте подивимося на інше, тепер
пункт, у якому підкреслено, що це може
ніколи не готували її до слави та
гламуру, які вона придбала, будучи
британською принцесою, і тут ми говоримо
про те, що саме Слава і який
саме гламур
був той, що  вона отримала, коли була
британською принцесою д-р.  Донна
віддаляється як оз начо метаболізує лаву зло
вода мачете лава ву ла отра мана
деякі іграшки запитують одинадцять Абулафія Принцеса О
Бретані, тож ця частина
інформації важлива, ми не можемо забрати цю
частину речення, тож як щодо
наступного речення Діана?  вихователька дитячого садка
в Лондоні, коли вона
зацікавила принца Чарльза, коли вона
зацікавила принца Чарльза,
ця частина речення розповідає нам про те,
коли саме щось сталося, тому ця
частина інформації важлива для нашого
речення, ми не можемо її опускати, ми не можемо
прийняти  це відкинуло, коли клопотання було розроблено
настільки інформативним письмом Івонни айударнос
Васлава Отомо, це визначальне відносне
речення, коли мама Данхема з горілчаної
коми рік потому народила принца
Вільяма, який був першим із двох її
синів, так чи важливо, хто принц
Вільям  чи так, ми насправді підкреслюємо,
що він був першим сином леді
Діани в цій частині інформації,
цій частині інформації  важливо, що
це визначальне відносне речення, ми
можемо фактично замінити слово who was
that у цьому випадку мій рух був на
хвилину однаковим, і вони взяли хто був
манекеном частинки Данема,
а останнє речення тут знаходиться в
кінці  за текстом там Romans уважно
стежили папараці, що призвело
до смертельної автомобільної аварії, в якій вона загинула в
Парижі в 1997 році, тут насправді є навіть
два речення так, після коми
є невизначальне відносне речення, яке
насправді пояснює як додаткову
інформацію  це дає додаткову
інформацію про ту саму подію, пізніше
ми описуємо важливу
інформацію, тому яка автомобільна
аварія, в якій вона вбила її в Парижі
в 1997 році, ця частина речення є
визначальною, тому вона дає
важливу інформацію, яка визначає, що
саме  автомобільна аварія була такою, оскільки
ви переглянули цю інформацію про
визначення невизначальних відносних речень
, давайте перейдемо до практики, наше
завдання тепер полягає в тому, щоб вибрати  виправте відносні
займенники та поставте дієслова в
потрібну форму, щоб ми фактично не просто
переглядали займенники, які нам потрібно
тут використати, а й давайте переглянемо, як ми
використовуємо прості форми дієслів минулого часу,
давайте подивимося на перше речення,
леді  Діана Спенсер, яка чи була
членом британської королівської сім'ї, народилася
в 1961 році, тому ми повинні перш за все
з'ясувати, кого чи
що нам потрібно вибрати тут, тому ми
говоримо про принцесу леді Діану
Спенсер, і ми  ми говоримо про особу
, тому ми будемо використовувати слово who,
яке не можна використовувати в цьому випадку, а
потім ми говоримо про минулі
події, тому, звичайно, ми будемо використовувати
форму минулого дієслова to be which is
either  was або were so was використовується в
однині were використовується для множини,
звичайно, тут ми говоримо про одну особу,
і тому нам потрібно буде
використовувати форму дієслова to be,
що саме так,
номер два у неї нормальний  тихе
виховання ми говоримо про  але минулі
події тут ми говоримо про
завершену дію, переміщення над amo pro mono
lugia, збереження a chasse away
Prometric Imam of Shabbat минула проста
форма deus Lama, тож яка
проста форма минулого дієслова to have
це безумовно має число  три
протягом кількох років вона перетворилася
з сором'язливого підлітка на найбільш
фотографовану людину на планеті
знову ми говоримо про минулі
події, і нам потрібно поставити зміну дієслова
у форму минулого простого, що
змінюється відповідно до таблиці
неправильних  дієслова no це дієслово є
звичайним дієсловом, це просто означає, що
закінчення потрібно додати, тож давайте подивимося
на дошку, яку
вона змінила від сором'язливого підлітка
№ 4
Діана була вихователькою в дитячому саду в
Лондоні, коли або чому вона назвала
інтереси принца  Чарльз,
тож чи ми описуємо причину, чи
ми описуємо час, коли Діана була
вихователькою в дитячому саду в Лондоні, ми можемо
припустити, що ця частина речення
розповідає нам про те, коли саме
сом  Все сталося, тому, коли ми
говоримо про час, нам потрібно
використати займенник відносний займенник, коли
номер 5
Діана спочатку нервувала на публіці,
але незабаром знову розвинула чарівну манеру,
ми говоримо про минуле
просте, тому нам потрібно використовувати  минула проста
форма дієслова to develop ми просто
додаємо Edie та до цього дієслова, щоб
зробити минуле простим від Jinan patrina
плюс todo, що схоже на ідею
need' Slava розробити це над Shabbat
beretta Manolo для Matias lama, і ми повинні
сказати  що Діана спочатку нервувала на
публіці, але незабаром у неї з'явилася чарівна
манера № 6. За їхнім романом
пильно слідкували папараці
, що призвело до її фатальної автокатастрофи, тому
після коми ми знаходимося в тому чи
іншому випадку, щоб посилатися на цю подію  звичайно
, немає того, що після коми
це невизначальне відносне речення. Тут
ми не можемо використовувати слово що, тому
ми будемо використовувати це, тому за їхнім романом
пильно стежили папараці, що
призвело до  смертельна автокатастрофа, а тепер
останнє речення номер сім для багатьох вона
буде просто Королевою сердець, тож ще
раз, яка б
форма однини дієслова to be в
минулому, що буде або був усвідомлений і
тут, звичайно, нам потрібно сказати  що занадто
багато, вона була просто Королевою сердець,
добре, тому тепер, коли ми виконали
вправу, яка допомогла нам
попрактикувати займенники, відносні речення
та прості форми минулого часу, це дієслова,
давайте подивимося на узагальнення
про минуле просте та  минуле безперервне,
яке було вивчено під час теми, так що
минуле просте використовується для розмови про минулі
завершені дії минулі звички або
стану ситуацій, які почалися і закінчилися
в минулому, а розповідь використовується, коли ми
говоримо про те, коли ми розповідаємо
історію, тому події історії  у
хронологічному порядку ви можете побачити
приклади на своїх екранах, які записують більшу частину
бюджету, а не
тріщину минулого, що продовжується до правильних дій, що
виконуються в певний час у
минулому або в певний час  Частина в
розповіді та в оповіді ми використовуємо його
безперервне минуле, щоб встановити сцену
початку оповідання. Гаразд, тепер, коли ви
побачили узагальнення
підсумок часів, давайте поглянемо на ваше
домашнє завдання, тож у вас є три
питання, на які ви дійсно можете відповісти
прямо зараз перше запитання що ви
знаєте про принцесу Діану, що ви
пам'ятаєте, ми читали текст про
леді Діану, тож які
найцікавіші факти ви дізналися,
подумайте, чи хотіли б ви зустрітися з
принцесою Діаною  я хотів би, щоб
третє запитання, що б ви хотіли
знати про принцесу Діану та Уайта,
які питання ви б поставили леді Д
і вашій домашній роботі, лише кілька слів
із тексту, який ми прочитали, скористайтеся
словником або пошуком Google
або іншим пошуком  двигун для створення
більшої кількості асоціацій для кожного
слова. Я б радив вам написати кілька
речень, використовуючи ці слова, і ви
також можете це зробити необов’язково, щоб ви
могли написати  лист до принцеси Діани
поставив їй три запитання про її життя,
тож це все на сьогодні, дуже
дякую за вашу увагу,
ми можемо почути Ballerini, тому дуже дякую, до
наступного разу, до побачення
[Музика]